Netflix CEO Reed Hastings had some
interesting things to say about the
future of cable television and believe
it or not yeah he thinks that things
dying pretty quickly we've got the quote
right here so what Hastings is referring
to here is that Nielsen is going to
start measuring Netflix traffic next
month so he goes on to say it's not very
relevant there's so much viewing that
happens on a mobile phone or an iPad
that Nielsen won't capture it's kind of
like the horse you know the horse was
good until we had the car the age of
broadcast TV will probably last until
2030 okay I mean this seems pretty
obvious we've talked a bunch about this
that people are cutting the cord left
and right so my first question to you
guys is have you guys cut yeah cord yet
you you're a cord cutter done you have
no cable none you're doing this all
online doing great and you're doing
great yes and your bill is down I don't
spend a hundred dollars a month on cable
yeah now Louis I know you're a big TV
watcher and you're in the biz I've been
right more than that on cable not
cutting the cord it's different though I
mean I do have to watch everything I
have to be up on everything I write
about television so I don't have the
option yet of cutting the cord at the
same time I think 20 30 is like I think
we're actually going to see the end of
broadcast well before that hi I think
it's coming faster than 20 30 yeah so to
your point I wanted to bring this up so
TV viewership dropped a full fifty
percent between 2002 and 2012 and that's
well before Netflix really a lot of that
the first half of that at least is
really before Netflix really sort of
picked up steam so yeah I'm with you I
think that this thing is going to happen
way before then I think it could happen
maybe in five years or something do you
miss anything do you feel like you've
lost anything by not having access to
the cable channel how much time I've
spent just like skipping through
channels looking for something to watch
and it's just and then I'll find
something I'll be like oh no it's fine
it's not like something I love ya and I
think I have a lot more personal time
now and it's great yeah what about net
neutrality because that to me is one of
the biggest issues that we have going on
today you know it's funny obama
appointed a guy who was a telecom
lobbyists to figure out the rules on net
neutrality and then you know but is it
two weeks ago Obama said that he's for
open and free internet yet he appointed
a guy to be in charge of it that's not
so another one of those things as per
our previous segment but how does this
make net neutrality that much more
important that if everyone's cut in the
cord it's always been important and
we've always worried that you know once
these telecom agencies who also happen
to be cable companies are able to
throttle netflix even more yeah they're
going to do it so this this is important
i mean this is an outdated model and we
can even see that exemplified by Nielsen
ratings failing to include online
numbers and it's it needs to it needs to
change or it needs to die one of those
things is happening yeah so for someone
like you who watches all this stuff that
your business is in this and there's and
forgetting people that's business in it
there's plenty of people that watch a
ton of TV that don't want to cut the
cord when this thing changes you think
the ala carte way of getting all your
channel so you'll just stop watching
certain I mean I hope yeah I think that
it's already happened I mean if you look
at now we can watch stuff on TV on
netflix on hulu on itunes and yahoo i
mean there's there's actually at this
point too much and I feel like it's
become there's too much TV to watch I
would say yeah I think we're going it to
a point where people start people stop
watching things just because there's so
many options start focusing more on a
network they really liked or on a show
they really liked and less on everything
right final thought of this what are you
guys watching these days I actually
watch a lot of Netflix you watch a lot
yeah it's like give me like two shows
that you're watching right I watched all
of orange is the new black back in one
weekend both seasons yep [ __ ] awesome
yeah and I'm catching up on old shows
that i didn't really but I either loved
or I wanted to watch to begin with
you're just watching battlestar loop i
know it's off netflix now it's been off
since like november i'll do a little
research is that what are you watching
what do you recommend to work i just
discovered the cosby show guys i just
wanted to be a little controversial no I
i watch everything I watched too much
like I said I'd watch everything and
then I wonder why don't associate life
um you had to say Cosby great yeah I had
to say cup I wanted to open the door
well that does bring me to one other
thing that I think is kind of cheating
cuz one thing about their I do think
there's something to be said for actual
programming on these channels like
something air is something to be said
for flicking without an appointment you
know you mean when you're just flicking
on like a Sunday afternoon
and flicking yeah you're going dirty can
ye going dirty uh squirting so we're
headed in that yeah no but when you
really like a Sunday afternoon and you
just flip flipping through the channels
right I'm not flicking your flipping
through the channels and you just catch
something as opposed to having to go
search for it I think we might lose a
little something with that you
definitely do it i think that there's a
reason why i prefer Golden Girls
marathon to getting my DVDs out there's
an elders I wouldn't let this take take
over but we'll get used to it you know
if I if I had a choice to pick the
apples I wanted a watch of a like an
eight hour long marathon I probably
would yeah once I got used to that idea
once you got used to it all right well
we shall see but the internet is here is
to stay and hopefully net neutrality
doesn't [ __ ] the whole thing up in case
my feelings on that are clear enough